some of the impact of what we're
building we will never know and to me
that's something that I'm proud of and
excited about my name is Jeremy fianc
I'm founder and Managing Partner of the
house fund and I'm 25 years old
the house fund is a proceed in seed
stage venture capital fund investing in
Berkeley student faculty and alumni
startups we're calling this a startup
Institute for Berkeley built to support
founders at all stages of their startup
journey
[Music]
it all started when I was a student
working on my own ideas with my friends
and we were looking for mentorship as
well as resources to take our ideas to
the next level we ended up launching a
series of clubs and by the time we
graduated our clubs had sparked 50
companies that had raised over 50
million dollars
[Music]
it's hard work launching a venture
capital fund it's there is no playbook
to to build this sort of product having
seen thousands of companies come out of
this community we have a good sense of
the big ideas when we see them we have a
sense of the passion and fire that we
see in an entrepreneur when you know
they really want to bring this company
to life
you
I don't know if I would consider myself
a super connector but I love bringing
together people at the right moment you
know how do you bring these people
together at the right time to help them
find their breakout opportunities this
is something I'm really passionate about
activating a community bringing people
together you know enabling amazing ideas
to me that that's what it means to be a
super connector
[Music]
you